hello everyone and welcome to the tie
breaks of the world rapid championship
after 13 rounds we have four people on
uh
nine points or is it maybe nine and a
half points doesn't really matter but
four people are tied it's magnus cross
and fabiano caruana noir because and
here
but only the two players
with the best additional criteria will
actually go into thai breaks and here
they are it's abdusathorov and the annie
punished they will brawl it out for
um
first prize uh let's check it out uh
they will play two blitz games and then
the
if the two blitz games are drawn they
don't go into armageddon uh but they
continue playing blitz indefinitely or
until someone wins uh which is a new
rule so some people like it some don't
but at least
a a rapid championship will not be
decided by armageddon in this case it
will be decided by blitz so this is the
second game of their match first game
nipple had the white pieces and he had a
promising position but uh it's a
three-minute blitz game uh he couldn't
take advantage of his position and the
game ended in the draw now abdusatrov
has the white pieces uh let's see what
happened in this one so abdusatrov opens
with c4 he goes for the english opening
knight to f6 we have knight to c3 e5
knight to f3 and the knight to c6 again
we have the four knights of the english
uh e4 uh and and now the so-called
nymphs of each variation and bishop to
b4 now we have d3 defending the e4 pawn
and d6 now we have h3 and a5
we have bishop to e2 and now there is a
game where h6 was played but here nipple
plays bishop back to c5 and it is now as
of move 7 that we have a completely new
game and both of them are playing
extremely quickly uh however uh
abdusathrov is playing a little bit
faster in the first game you could
really see how incredibly fast he was um
he started with three minutes and after
like 20 moves he had maybe three minutes
and and 30 seconds on the clock nipple
also uh had a
a pretty pretty fast the start but not
as fast and in the second game
abdusatrov also was playing um well is
seemingly much faster we have castles uh
and h6 now we have bishop to e3 bishop
captures f captures and now nipple
castles we have queen to e1 now abu
satyar wants to play knight h4 he wants
to bring the knight to f5 he wants to
bring the queen to g3 maybe h4 uh
depending on what nipple plays with
knife to e7 and knight the h for now we
have knight to g6 and now knight to f5
preparing to bring the queen into the
game we have c6 and now queen to g3 and
now you don't want all this pressure on
the g file so here nipple removes one of
the attackers we have not f captures by
the rook capture so he can play rook f a
to f1 and double up on the f file we
have knight to h7 and now rook a2f1
uh and now as uh well we've prepared
this move queen is coming to h4 uh queen
to h4 nipple offers a queen trade king
to h2 abdu satoru now uh defends the
queen queen captures and king capture so
the queens get traded off but the abu
sathrov already has a very active king
knight to e7 attacking the rook rogue
back to f2 we have knight to g5 uh and
now h4 kicking away the knight knight to
the e6 and now bishop to g4 we have
knight to c7 and now knight the a4 so
putting a lot of pressure here knight to
b6
is definitely an option we have f6 now
strengthening the center but now d4
striking in the center you want black to
capture of course and we're gonna force
this uh by by moving our rooks all the
way uh to the d file so here we have
rook f to d8 but now rook to d2 and uh
unless black captures here we're just
going to double up on the d file and
capture on e5 so nipple doesn't want to
capture he plays b5 instead and now
attacking the knight and trying to mess
up the the central pawn structure now c
captures on b for knight captures on b4
and now rook to c1 uh very interesting
here was uh captures an e5f captures on
e5 and now knight to b6 attacking the
rook and when the rook moves now we have
this very nice knight to c4 idea but
it's a three-minute blitz game you can't
see everything now this is being
threatened because the rook is
undefended uh also we're threatening to
play a four kick away tonight win this
spawn so this would be very good for
white uh but okay rook the c1 was played
now comes rook a to b8 and now knight to
c3 uh we have king f7 nepal starts
bringing his king into the game and h5
not allowing any g6 moves so knight
captures on c3 rook captures on c3 and
now rook to b5
uh we have bishop to e2 kicking away
nepal's rook rook back to b6 and now
bishop the c4 with check and now
you could go back and probably you
should go back but nifo strikes in the
center with the d5 uh we have d captures
oh sorry d captures on e5 uh f captures
on e5 and now e captures on d5 we have c
captures on e5 and now e4
and you can see that the pawn can't move
if you if you move it then the king will
be in check and well how do you defend
the pawn here it's uh simply not
happening so here king f6 nepal and pins
but now bishop captures on d5 we have
knight capture spawn captures and king
to g5 so now abdusatrov is up upon
but it's not going to be easy to convert
this so rook to e3 going after the e5
pawn and now king captures an
we have rook captures on a on e5 king to
g6 and now d6 uh advancing the pawn
attacking the a5 pawn so trying to trade
this one for this one but then you will
have two connected pass pawns on the
queen side so here a4 uh but now d7 we
have king to f7 and now rook to f2 with
check we have king to g6 and now rook to
e7 now abdusatro wants to play rook to
f7 and then capture on g7 so rook to d6
going after this pawn but now just rook
after f7 we rook the d3 check king to f4
now comes rook to b8
uh and the rook captures on g7 with
check and now nipple play king the f5
which is a pretty pretty uh bad move
because you can uh deliver checkmate in
two moves uh however luckily for nepal
abu satyarva missed it it's actually
just rook to e5 checking h4 and rook to
g4 checkmate but uh so much is at stake
and the players are very low on the
clock uh he misses it after nepo's um
king to h5 he just goes king to f5 and
now we have rook captures on b2 grabbing
the spawn and again the idea is still
here but rook the g8 is played preparing
to promote this pawn and now we have
rook beat d2 now threatening uh to pick
up the pawn but also guarding the d8
square and again it's the exact same
idea only now it's much much cooler here
you can actually play rooked g5 check
and after h captures deliver this rook
to h7 checkmate uh which is of course a
very nice king covers this rook covers
this
or if you don't capture if the king just
moves then it's the exact same checkmate
with rook to e4 so again this was
possible but um abu sadr missed it he
played rook to e1 now he's threatening
rook to h1 checkmate now comes rook d5
check king to f6 rook the d6 sure king
f5 rook six the d5 check king to f4 and
now uh nepo should go rook two to d4
check and continue uh checking the white
king with a lot of drawing chances but
instead he goes with this rook and now
he allows the white king to escape king
the g3 was played rook d to the three
check king h2 and now rook to d5 but
also it doesn't matter if you capture on
d7 it's the simple rookie 5 checking the
h4 and now g3 check the black king has
no squares you have to give up the rook
which is similar to what happened in the
game so instead rook to d5 was played
now abdul sathrov just
gets the the rook away from the fifth
rank he plays the eighth queen brings
the queen into the game and forces nepal
to capture this queen so rook captures
the queen rook the e5 with check came to
h4 and g3 check and he was in this
position and move 56 that yanipon
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here you have to capture
the pawn then rook captures here and now
you're just down the rook if rook d2
check we can simply block with rook to
g2 and that's it completely winning
position for abdusatorov uh who
pretty much crushed everyone and uh well
he he
regardless of what uh you know everyone
is saying and it's like magnus says in
the quote above the board squabbles
about the rules aside what an absolutely
incredible achievement so uh he only
lost the one game in this entire event
to
i believe anton korobov and he just
destroyed everyone including uh world
champion magnus cross an incredibly
incredible event uh and it it's just
that he played so convincingly even
after his game against magnus which was
uh pretty much uh all engine moves he he
gave magnus that one little tiny chance
that uh magnus mystery remaneuvered the
night there was that king the b8 move or
uh or knight to c5 but magnus missed it
and then uh well there was nothing more
it was just a draw and magnus was trying
to force a win and then abuse punished
him uh but even he even after that game
he said that he wasn't uh too impressed
with his game against magnus that he was
uh looking forward to to playing the
other games and trying to play them uh
even better and it would seem that he
was very much able to do that and he was
he was in a lot of trouble in the last
two games
but he managed to
uh you know come on top and and
not lose them uh he was lost against
fidosev and then again again in the
final round against duda magnus even at
some point during his game with hikaru
uh got up from the table and went to
check up on um another begs game and
he's uh sorry on uh
yeah another game against duda and he
saw the duda was winning so i guess
magnus wasn't all that impressed he
didn't think nother back was going to go
into the tie breaks but then duda
couldn't finish him off the game ended
in a draw and that's how we got uh
abdusatrov and nipomishi here in the in
the tie breaks and uh saturn of
completely completely crushed him
uh so uh big congratulations to to
abdusattarov uh i believe uh second is
yan and magnus is third yeah and fabi in
for fourth place unfortunately for fabi
uh tough break for him he shouldn't have
agreed to that to draw but uh you know
it it's weird yeah not knowing the rules
like that
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it maybe i will have time to
cover uh a few more games so uh do use
hashtag suggestion with your favorite
favorite games from the rapid event uh
tomorrow we are continuing with the
blitz event i believe it's gonna be uh
it's gonna be really awesome
uh so yeah uh once again hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank
catherine uh malta jack schroeder
jeffrey ridden or evgeny brisken and
david kimura for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
incredible event until it ends which
means for two more days see you soon